hast du sie noch alle
wie meinst du dass kurse rein entwürfe
was wo meine in würfel sind
ich habe deine entwürfe nicht du hast
meine semesterarbeit geklaut nein
lotta ich hab dann lass mich in ruhe
lasst meine sachen in ruhe mein freund
hast du dir schon geschnappt das reicht
aber das mit jonas ist vorbei was ist
denn los
soll ich mal mit dir reden klein
ablehnung
ich
wir haben
auch lena das ist wirklich schlimm dass
du nicht da bist
ich brauche jemanden zum reden ja ich
kann mitreden aber er ist auch der
einzige hier
das tut mir wirklich leid dass ihr
streit habt aber auch wenn du jetzt
jemanden etwas kennen gelernt hast
kannst du doch nicht hier einfach alles
hinschmeißen
reza ist wirklich ein guter kerl ja
ergibt sich jetzt wieder richtig viel
mühe auch bei seinem studium ja er hatte
einen durchhänger aber lena er liebt
dich wirklich liebst du schon
was ist passiert